voilà pour cette audition de jean
gaubert le médiateur national de
l'énergie qui a donc été entendu par les
sénateurs de la commission d' enquête
sur les autorités administratives
indépendantes
objectif de cette commission denquête et
bien voir justement 6 et d'autorités
administratives indépendantes qui ont
acquis un rôle très important dans notre
système institutionnel dont justement
pas trop de pouvoir et cela au détriment
des pouvoirs exécutif et législatif la
loi justement c'est ce qui occupe ce
matin les sénateurs qui participent au
débat sur le bilan annuel de
l'application des lois a rendez vous
incontournable du sénat on peut déjà
dire qu'au titre de la cession 2013 2014
les résultats sont comparables aux
années précédentes avec un taux de
transformation en textes d'application
de 65% et avec un délai entre la loi et
la parution des décrets d'application
qui reste stable aux alentours de vie
moi tout de suite donc on prend la
direction de la salle clemenceau mes
chers collègues en parallèle avec les
travaux des groupes de réflexion sur
deux méthodes de travail j'avais redit
l'importance que nous attachons au
contrôle parlementaire qui est pour nous
une priorité
me semble-t-il de même rang que la
fonction législative
à nous de combinés de considérer dans
notre agenda cette double fonction
ces deux endroits contre le recours une
grande diversité et je le rappelle il ya
en moyenne 5000 questions écrites par an
avec le rappel monsieur le ministre j'ai
eu l'occasion de vous le dire
j'en profite encore une fois le rappel
de notre attachement aux délais de
réponse
et notamment sur des questions qui sont
importantes par rapport à l'actualité
qu'elle soit législatif ou qu'elle soit
tout simplement événementiel les
questions orales du mardi matin les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
le contrôle est d'ailleurs une des
marques du sénat et et je pense que nous
avons une place particulière pour
contrôler avec détermination et
efficacité
au delà de ce qui est naturel dans une
démocratie de la confrontation politique
le nouvel article 24 de la constitution
je le rappelle le parlement vote la loi
et contrôler l'action du gouvernement
il évalue les politiques publiques alors
nous allons dans cette forme un peu
nouvelle mais n'est que partiellement
nouvelle d'ailleurs dans cette salle
clémenceau ouvrir et je donne la parole
au président de la délégation du bureau
chargé du travail parlementaire du
contrôle et des études vice président du
sénat monsieur claude bérit-debat vous
avez la parole mans / collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
présidents des commissions permanentes
peu chers collègues comme tous les ans
depuis 2012
nous voici réunis en séance publique
pour faire le point sur l'application
des lois en présence du secrétaire
d'état chargé des relations avec le
parlement
cette année vous aurez cependant noté de
différence notable de procédure
nous siégeons en salle clémenceau sans
doute mieux approprié que l'hémicycle
pour un débat de contrôle de ce type
et comme l'a décidé le bureau du sénat
la synthèse des observations des
commissions permanentes
m'a été confié en ma qualité de
président de la dégradation du bureau au
travail parlementaire et au contrôle des
années précédentes ce travail est
effectué dans par une instance ad hoc
présidée par notre collègue david
assouline dont je tiens à saluer
l'excellence de son travail
tirant les conséquences de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008
il a beaucoup contribué à diffuser la
nouvelle culture de contrôle et
d'évaluation
au delà des différences formelle
l'essentiel est la vigilance et la sable
que le sénat consacre depuis plus de 40
ans à une bonne mise en application des
lois votées par le parlement
vous trouverez dans mon rapport écrit
tous les chiffres et toutes les données
quand ils qualitative de la dernière
session en l'occurrence l'année
parlementaire 2013 2014
ce matin je me contenterai dont dans
récapituler les points essentiels tels
que j'ai pu les présenter en conférence
des présidents le 27 mai dernier
les données ont été élaborées à partir
des bilans détaillés des commissions
permanentes et des statistiques de la
direction de la législation et du
contrôle du sénat après recoupements
avec les des chiffres quasi concordants
du secrétariat général du gouvernement
nous avons également eu l'honneur et le
plaisir de recevoir le nouveau
secrétaire général du gouvernement
monsieur marc guillaume le 19 mai
dernier quelques semaines seulement
après son entrée en fonctions en
présence des présidentes et présidents
des commissions permanentes ou de leurs
représentants de ce bilan
je retiendrai cette grande tendance
tout d'abord une production législative
soutenue sur l'année 66 doigts ont été
promulguées hors convention
internationale contre 50 l'année
précédente soit plus de 30%
d'augmentation sur l'ensemble 40% des
lois et man ont été d'initiative
parlementaire le sénat avec neuf
propositions de loi a été à lui seul à
l'origine de presque une loi sur cette
deuxième point en nombre de lois le
pourcentage d'applications total ou
partiel atteint 94%
mais comme je l'expliqué dans mon
rapport écrit ce chiffre impressionnant
n'a qu'une signification relative 27 des
66 loi de l'année naples est d'ailleurs
aucune mesure réglementaire ont par la
loi alors de loi d'application directe
troisième point le décompte par mesure
sur l'ensemble de la législature dont
depuis le 20 juin 2012 me semble plus
révélateur le secrétaire général du
gouvernement annonce à ce jour un taux
de 65% qui rejoint nos propres
estimations
nous avons également établi le
pourcentage de parution des textes
nécessaires à la mise en oeuvre des
mesures législatives de la précédente
session qui s'élève à ce jour à 55%
là encore c'est un simple indicateur
tendancielle car il ne parle pas en
compte tous les textes déjà parus ou
encore apparaître après le 31 mars 2015
au total on peut considérer que le taux
réel d'application des lois tourne
aujourd'hui autour de 65 % ce taux appel
de ma part deux observations on pourra
juger
on pourrait d'abord pardon le juger
insuffisant ou regretté qu' stands qui
stagne depuis cinq ans certes il ya
encore des progrès à tendre mais le taux
actuel est tout de même très supérieur
au pourcentage calamiteux observé avant
2010 qui tournait entre seulement 15 et
30%
ce pourcentage global masque de gros
écarts entre les différentes commissions
par exemple seulement 30% pour les lois
relevant de la commission des affaires
économiques contre 95 % comme pour la
commission de la culture de son côté le
secrétaire général du gouvernement a
reconnu qu'il y avait aussi des écarts
sensibles entre les ministères quatrième
point
autre tendance dans la durée sur 54 loi
votée en dés
vu du casier de la 14e j nature du 20
juin 2012 au 30 septembre 2013 seulement
de loi n'ont pas encore connu aucun
début de mise en application
autrement dit le stock de loi
durablement inappliquée n'augmentent pas
même s'il est trop tôt pour tirer des
conclusions définitives
cinquième point concernant les délais de
publication une circulaire de février
2008 donne au ministère six mois à
compter de la promulgation d'une loi
pour faire apparaître leurs textes en
pratique ce délai rarement respectée en
raison de la complexité du processus de
rédaction des décrets l'encore la charge
de travail est très inégale selon les
ministères certains sont submergés de
décret quand d'autres nand rédige
presque jamais l'an dernier seulement
30% des textes d'application sont sortis
dans les six mois
mais ce pourcentage n'a rien d'alarmant
car en général les dépassements restent
dans la limite du raisonnable sur 491
décret d'application de la présente
session
86 % sont sortis à moins de nom au total
le délai moyen de parution des décrets
d'application tourne autour de 8 mois et
saint geours sixième point cette année
encore le seul vrai point noir dans le
dépôt je devrais plutôt dire d'un
l'absence de dépôt des rapports demandés
par le parlement monsieur ministre sur
la moyenne des dix dernières années
seulement 60% des loi demandant aux
rapports ont été suivies d'effets c'est
une lacune dénonciez depuis des années
mais qui ne s'améliore pas au fil des
sessions
cela devrait nous conduire à nous
interroger sur les raisons de ce
phénomène
peut-être ne demande ou dont trop de
rapport
un report est aussi assez souvent une
concession du gouvernement
un échange de retrait d'un amendement
dont on peut s'interroger sur sur ce
type de modalités ou de pratique mais le
constat est là et quels qu'en soient les
raisons bonnes ou mauvaises
le défaut de remise des rapports à une
atteinte regrettable à l'exercice par le
sénat de sa fonction constitutionnel de
contrôle
le dernier point sur lequel je souhaite
attirer l'attention du gouvernement et
d'ordre plus qualitatif la pratique mon
cas c'est souvent les textes
d'application ne sont pas pleinement
fidèle aux lois qui sont assez appliqué
on assiste même parfois un phénomène de
distorsion cumulatives
le décret s'écarte un peu de la loi
la circulaire ses cartes à son tour du
décret et des interprétations en
interprétation le droit appliqué sur le
terrain n'est plus conforme à
l'intention initiale du législateur
les îles lau qu on trouve souvent
l'occasion d'observer des situations de
ce genre et j'en ai fait ses remontées
lors de la rencontre nous avons eu avec
le secrétaire général du gouvernement
c'est quelque chose sur lequel il faut
réfléchir alors d'autres pistes de
réflexion ont été évoqués lors de
l'audition du secrétaire général du
gouvernement en particulier sur les
retards dans les réponses ministérielles
aux questions des sénateurs mais le
temps me manque que pour le développer
en conclusion je crois légitime de dire
que les chiffres de 2013 2014
sans être exceptionnel monsieur le
ministre vont dans le bon sens il faut
en donner d'actes au gouvernement il a
pris cette question à bras le corps sous
votre coordination monsieur le ministre
et elle fait désormais l'objet d'une
communication mensuel au conseil des
ministres
innovation dont on ne peut que se
réjouir
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues les procédures
et les techniques de contrôle évolué
d'une année sur l'autre mais
l'application des lois
reste un combat de tous les jours le
sénat et ses commissions permanentes de
six impliquent activement et y déploie
une grande expertise
c'est à mes yeux une activité de
contrôle parlementaire au meilleur sens
du
hermes non pas un combat contre le
gouvernement mais un effort aux côtés du
gouvernement est au service de nos
concitoyens
c'est une démarche démocratique
essentiel car la loi votée par le
parlement exprime la volonté générale
et il importe d'en faire à tous les
niveaux l'application la plus fidèle et
la plus de profit de possibles je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président pour ce
rapport est le rapport d'information qui
est naturellement à la disposition de
chacune et de chacun nos colères que
maintenant donner la parole et à chacune
des commissions au travers de leur
président de représentants et nous
commençons par la commission des
affaires économiques je vais donner la
parole à notre collègue michel houel
pour cinq minutes
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
les présidents jean-claude audois qui ne
peut être présent ce matin au sénat m'a
demandé de l'excusé est de vous
présenter le bilan d'application des
lois relevant du champ de compétence de
la commission des affaires économiques
pour la session parlementaire 2013 2014
sur les 34 loi sur les 34 loi dont
l'application est suivi cette année par
la commission des affaires économiques
quatorze sont totalement applicable
comme l'année dernière il est à noter
qu'aucune noir figurant dans le bilan
n'apparaît comme totalement appliquée
l'activité législative de la commission
a été soutenue durant la session
parlementaire 2013 2014 avec l'adoption
de cinq projets de loi importants tant
pour leur contenu que le fait de la
longueur de certains textes prévoyant un
nombre impressionnant de mesures
réglementaires d'application trois
propositions de loi ou légalement été
voté au cours de cette période de
référence deux sont d'origine
sénatoriale est directement applicable
l'étude des vins loi qui ne se sont que
partiellement applicable abouti un bilan
plus contrasté
l'exemple le plus emblématique et on est
la loi du 24 mars 2014 pour l'accès au
logement et un urbanisme rey devait dite
loi allure pour laquelle 210 renvoi des
deux verres des débats ou arrêtés sont
prévues je pense personnellement que
c'est aux allures qu'on devra vraiment y
retravailler la couper en deux autant on
peut considérer que ce qui a été pris et
votée par les assemblées me semble
ajusté pour le partir à port leucate r
est le propriétaire
mais autant sur l'urbanisme la loi
allure a été dans énormément de communes
une véritable catastrophe et une levée
de boucliers sache tient vraiment elle
souligné et entre autres dans ma commune
quand je suis en seine-et-marne monsieur
le ministre donc dans un secteur
sensible du nord du département et c'est
sûr que lorsque vous avez mille mètres
carrés terrain dans la commune et que
d'un seul coup mille mètres carrés à
côté de terrain apparaissent et on en
fait trois lots ce qui veut dire
qu'après on peut plus le laisser entrer
les voitures on les laisse sur la
chaussée c'est vraiment là y ait quelque
chose à voir de voter l'étude des 20
lois qui ne sont que partiellement
applicable abouti un bilan plus
contrasté
l'exemple le plus emblématique on est la
loi du 24 mars 2014 pour l'accès au
logement je viens de dire et surtout de
l'urbanisme rêver reut le rénover pour
laquelle 210 renvoient vers des décrets
ou arrêtés sont prévues à ce jour cette
fois ci affiche un taux de parution des
textes réglementaires très bas qui
s'établit à 16% seulement puisque 33
mesures ont jusqu'à présent été prise il
est à noter que la loi du 20 décembre
2014 relative à la simplification de la
vie des entreprises et portant diverses
dispositions de simplification et de
clarification du droit et des procédures
administratives et le projet de loi pour
la croissance
l'activité et l'égalité des chances
économiques en cours d'examen modifie
plusieurs dispositions de la loi les
conséquences de ces modifications sur
les mesures réglementaires à prendre
sont à ce stade encore difficile à
évaluer mais l'abandon de certains
dispositifs est probable deux autres
doivent voter durant l'année
parlementaire 2013-2014 affiche un taux
d'application peu satisfaisant avec un
peu de 1 peu plus d'un quart des mesures
réglementaires attendues et déjà
publiées il s'agit respectivement de la
loi du 31 juillet 2014 relatives à
l'économie sociale et solidaire 28% des
mesures prises et de la loi du 18 juin
2014 relatives à l'artisanat aux
commerces et aux très petites
entreprises
26 % seulement des tours d'application
lorsque l'on regarde plus en arrière
dans le stock des lois suivi par la
commission force est de constater que
très peu de mesures réglementaires moins
d'une dizaine environ été prise par les
lois antérieures à 2013 à plusieurs
rares exceptions exception sur les 34
mois dans l'application est suivi cette
année par la commission des affaires
économiques
une seule a fait l'objet de la remise
d'un rapport en vertu de l'article 67 de
la loi du 9 décembre 2004 de
simplification du droit devant le bilan
établi en 2013 le rapport relatif à la
mise en application de la loi du 17 mars
2014 relatives à la consommation a été
remis au parlement le 20 décembre 14
soit soit plus de neuf mois après la
promulgation du texte au lieu des six
mois annoncé par la loi 2004
comme l'année dernière il faut enfin
déploré la grave défaillance dont fait
preuve l'administration quelquefois en
ce qui concerne la remise des rapports
au parlement
les chiffres sont éloquents trois
rapports seulement été rendu au cours de
la période étudiée cette année sur des
textes que nous avons suivi pour mémoire
les lois votées sur la période du 1er
octobre 2013 au 30 septembre 2014
prévoyait au total la remise de 27
rapport la loi allure a été à lui seul
comprenant neuf rapports et aucun n'a
paru pour l'instant il n'a pas vu le
jour
c'est l'inefficacité de la mesure étant
depuis longtemps démontrées je crois en
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
qu'il nous faut absolument combattre
cette solution de facilité qui consiste
à prévoir la remise d'un rapport sur un
dispositif dont on peut obtenir la docte
l'adoptation l'adoption dans la loi ces
rapports coûte cher et nous coûte très
cher pour conçu pour conclure monsieur
le ministre je dirais que la commission
des affaires économiques a dû traiter
une volonté législative très importante
ces dernières années plusieurs centaines
de textes d'application sont attendus et
le rythme s'accélère
dans ces conditions il ne faut guère
s'étonner que l'application des lois
puissent être satisfaisante
alors monsieur le ministre nous avons
peut-être une solution à la la
commission des affaires économiques et
basse et de moins légiférer
merci bien sûr cette proposition bercy
collègue michel louette au long de la
commission des affaires économiques à
part en les maintenant au président jean
pierre raffarin président de la
commission des affaires étrangères la
défense et des forces armées
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme
chacun le sait l'essentiel de la quitte
et législatives la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées consistant l'examen de
projets de loi autorisant la
ratification l'approbation de traiter ou
d'accords internationaux
ainsi au cours de la session en
2013-2014 de sénat adopté 22 accords
internationaux ont le vent de la
compétence de la commission certains ces
accords n'ont pas été examiné par
l'assemblée nationale et toutes les lois
n'ont donc pas été promulguée
toutefois les conventions n'entre pas
dans le champ du bilan que nous dressons
aujourd'hui en dehors des conventions de
lois ont été promulguées au cours de la
session 2013 2014 la loi du 18 décembre
de détresse de programmation militaire
2014-2019 que le sénat souhaite pouvoir
actualiser prochainement et la loi du 7
juillet 2014 d'orientation de
programmation relative à la politique de
développement et de solidarité
internationale
ces deux lois de programmation ont
constitué deux rendez vous législatifs
importants
la commission affaires étrangères s'est
également saisie pour avis de la loi du
1er juillet 2014 relatives aux activités
des privés de protection des navires à
la date du 31 mars 2015 la commission
suit l'application de cinq lois adoptées
jusqu'au 30 septembre 2014 est
applicable donc à des degrés divers
le bilan fait apparaître plusieurs
motifs de satisfaction en premier lieu
la loi d'orientation sur le
développement a été rendue totalement
applicable
moins de six mois après sa promulgation
en deuxième le nez contrairement au
précédent bilan d'application des lois
la commission n'a plus de loi qui soit
totalement inappliqué à une des mesures
réglementaires que nous attendions
depuis trois ans promettent pour
permettre l'application au moins
partielle de la loi du 28 juillet 2011
tendant à faciliter l'utilisation des
réserves militaires et civiles en cas de
crise majeure vient d'être prise sous la
forme d'un décret en conseil d'état du
16 mars 2015 porte en amélioration et
simplification des règles de gestion de
la réserve militaire
le rapport d'application publié par la
commission pour le contrôler
l'application des lois en juillet 2014
on s'en souvient avait considéré que
l'absence de décret d'application d'une
loi censée garantir la continuité de la
ville nationale 3 ans après sa
progression était une situation
pathologique tout à fait anormal et
préconisé que les décrets d'application
soient publiés dans les plus brefs
délais cette analyse prend toute sa
dimension dans le contexte des attentats
de janvier dernier et de la mobilisation
de nos forces armées sur le territoire
national notamment dans le cadre de l'
opération sentinel le projet de loi
d'actualisation de loi de programmation
militaire que nous examinerons juillet
prévoit que le nombre de réservistes
soit augmenté de manière significative
c'est ce contexte de particulière
gravité qui nous a conduit monsieur le
président à l'accélération du calendrier
que nous appelons de nos voeux
en troisième lieu la loi du 18 décembre
2013 relatives à la programmation
militaire pour les années 2014 à 2019
dont nous examinerons donc actualisation
a reçu 94 % des mesures réglementaires
attendues 94% avec vingt mesures
réglementaires prises au 31 mars 2015
j'attire votre attention sur les 3
derniers décrets en conseil d'état
pliez publié le 29 mars 2015 relative à
la lutte contre la cyber criminalité
la récente attaque dont a été victime
tv5monde en souligner toute la nécessité
j'ajoute que la commission a bien reçu
en juin 2014 le rapport sur l'exécution
de loi de programmation militaire
préalablement au débat d'orientation
budgétaire rapport qui est prévu par
l'article 10 de la loi ainsi que les
deux bilans semestriels détaillés
demandé par son article 8 qui ont été
reçues respectivement en juin et en
octobre de l'année dernière le ministre
de la défense est venu lui-même nous
présenter ces rapports devant la
commission en quatrième lieu un rapport
global sur la mise en application de
cette loi était déposé au parlement le
28 juillet 2014 soit sept mois après sa
promulgation
en application de l'article 67 de cette
loi en dépit de ce retard la commission
a pris acte avec satisfaction
pourtant qui a été précédé par l'envoi
la commission juin 2014 d'un rapport du
ministère de la défense sur l'analyse de
la programmation 2014 2010 ce document
très complet faisait l'objet d'une
diffusion reste la commission a un
regret toutefois exprimé celui de ne pas
avoir reçu en temps et en heure le
rapport d'application pour la loi
d'orientation et de programmation
relative à la politique de développement
et de solidarité and can nationale qui
aurait dû être transmis au sénat au plus
tard le 7 janvier 2004 ce rapport vient
de nous est cependant transmis seulement
début mai c'est d'autant plus
regrettable que tous les textes
d'application attendus ont bien été pris
dans un délai de moins de six mois après
la promulgation en conclusion monsieur
le président de vous présentant ce bilan
avec une conviction qui nous prêtent
plutôt positif 6
monsieur le président je vas t'en donner
la parole au président de la commission
des affaires sociales de notre collègue
alain milon oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues au vu du bilan établi par la
commission des affaires sociales je ne
peux qu'appuyer les propos et les
principaux constats dressés par le
président claude berri et de bas tout
d'abord le niveau de mise en application
des lois relevant notre commission
apparaît nettement plus satisfaisant que
par le passé au 31 mars dernier 78% des
mesures attendues pour les textes de
l'année 2014 2013 étaient intervenus
c'est un taux quasiment identique à
celui constaté l'année précédente à la
même période alors même que le nombre de
dispositions appliquées a doublé d'une
année sur l'autre passant de 132 à 265
et que nous nous situons sur un niveau
historiquement élevé de production
législative dans le champ social
il faut donc saluer ce réel progrès tout
en souhaitant bien entendu que les
efforts de mise en application rapide
soit poursuivi ce satisfecit doit
cependant être nuancée par un deuxième
constat qui est d'ailleurs récurrent
celui de fortes disparités selon les
textes
ainsi les textes qui compte qu'ils
traduisent par dont les priorités de la
politique gouvernementale sont
généralement rapidement mises en oeuvre
c'est le cas des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale de la loi sur les
retraites ou de la loi sur la formation
professionnelle
nous avons le sentiment que l'exécutif
est parfois moins empressé de mettre en
oeuvre certains texte d'origine
parlementaire
nous avons évoqué en commission
l'application à la fonction publique de
la loi permettant le dont deux jours de
repos un parent d'enfants gravement
malades
les décrets ont finalement été publié au
journal officiel il ya quelques jours le
29 mai
nous nous sommes également inquiété de
l'absence de parution à ce jour du
décret nécessaire à l'expérimentation
des maisons de retraite
alors qu'un cahier des charges de cet
écrit meilleure notation a été défini en
septembre 2014 par la haute autorité de
santé
je rappelle que cette loi a été initiée
au sénat par notre ancien collègue
muguette dini et que le décret est
nécessaire pour sécuriser le cadre
juridique et le financement des maisons
de naissance qui n'existe aujourd'hui
que sous la forme de projet pilote nous
constatons aussi pour certains
disposition des délais d'application
anormalement long il s'est dit tous les
cinq ans entre l'apparition de la loi
hpst de 2009 et celle en août 2014 du
décret d'application de son article 8
ouvrant la possibilité de créer des
fondations hospitalières associant les
acteurs publics ou privés de la
recherche clinique et c'est il ya un
mois à peine qui est paru le décret
approuvant les statuts de la fondation
hospitalière
ap hp pour la recherche al'inverse il
faut reconnaître qu'une parution très
rapide des textes réglementaires n'est
pas toujours non plus gage d'efficacité
nous voyons avec les difficultés liées à
l'application des décrets relatifs aux
comptes personnels de prévention d'un
pénibilité elles ont contraint le
gouvernement à revenir en partie sur le
dispositif dans le projet de loi sur le
dialogue social
le président berry de bar a également
évoqué dans ce rapport à la question
essentielle de la conformité des textes
d'application avec l'intention du
législateur le cas des divergences
existent par exemple
l'arrêté de février 2015 relatif à
l'article 28 de loi de bioéthique de
juillet 2011 sur les conditions de
formation et d'expérimentation des
praticiens exerçant les activités
d'assistance médicale à la procréation
avec tiers donneur n'a que très
partiellement était satisfait à nos yeux
l'amendement du sénat qui visait à
établir des règles de bonnes pratiques
en la matière en effet cet arrêté ne
fixe pas les critères que nous
attendions pour définir de manière
objective la marge d'appréciation
laissée aux praticiens
s'agissant de l'adéquation entre les
caractéristiques physiques des parents
des celle du donneur
enfin je confirme aussi le faible taux
de remise de rapports au parlement qui
invite me semble-t-il à davantage de
discernement sur les demandes formulées
voilà monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ce bilan contrasté qui
s'inscrit dans une tendance qui nous
paraît néanmoins plutôt positive je suis
convaincu qu'elle pourra l'être
davantage encore avec une meilleure
préparation et évaluation préalable des
textes et une attention renforcée de
l'exécutif aux dispositions issues de
l'initiative parlementaire
merci monsieur le président je donne la
parole maintenant madame la présidente
de la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication de la
ville entre catherine morin desailly
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues donc comme chaque année nous
sommes réunis pour un moment important
qui traduisent solennellement l'exercice
de notre fonction de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement je dois dire
que pour ce qui concerne la commission
de la culture l'éducation de la
communication c'est un exercice auquel
nous sommes très attachés
je note que depuis plusieurs années les
gouvernements successifs se sont
efforcés de raccourcir les délais de
parution des textes d'application des
lois que nous adoptons et en pratique je
note que la plupart des textes attendus
pour l'application des grandes lois
votées depuis le début de la législature
dans les secteurs qui concernent qui
relève la compétence de notre commission
sont désormais paru ce qui confirme les
observations générales qui ont été
formulées par le président berry débat
maintenant si je rentre dans le détail
je voudrais dire que deux textes
manquent encore pour l'application
complète de la loi de refondation de
l'école de juillet 2013 envisagée pour
l'arrêté définissant la période
c'est le contenu des visites médicales
restent encore en attente l'autre décret
prévu et non encore prix concerne
l'attestation de maîtrise du socle
commun de connaissances de compétences
et des cultures par le diplôme national
du brevet selon les informations qui ont
été communiquées ce de ce décret devrait
être publié en 2016 ou 2017
il me fournit une transition pour
évoquer un phénomène croissant celui des
mesures d'application n'ont prévu
expressément
il n'a échappé à personne que le
gouvernement a pris il ya quelques jours
un décret et un arrêté sur la réforme du
collège
sans entrer dans la police mais son
contenu de la réforme
il est certain que l'absence de mention
de textes désigné a entre guillemets
repenser le collège unique mention qui
figurent dans le rapport annexé à la loi
de refondation de l'école mais pas dans
le texte de loi comme on dit a contribué
à alimenter l'effet de surprise
la ministre de l'éducation nationale et
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche annoncé la publication d'ici à
la rentrée prochaine des nouveaux
programmes
ceux ci feront l'objet d'une circulaire
qui permettra très concrètement de
préparer la mise en oeuvre de la réforme
des programmes du primaire comme du
secondaire
en 2013 la question de l'approbation de
ses programmes par le législateur a été
tranché cette proposition n'a pas été
suivi c'est pourquoi il me paraît
essentiel qu'elles nous soient
transmises en temps et en heure la
circulaire annoncé par la ministre
prévoir dès l'origine un calendrier
prévisionnel pour l'adoption des
circulaires pourrait d'ailleurs
constituer un pas supplémentaire dans la
bonne direction
deux décrets pour l'application de la
loi relatifs cette fois à l'enseignement
supérieur et à la recherche de juillet
2013 reste encore en attente
il semblerait que le décret fixant les
critères d'attribution des logements
destinés aux étudiants ainsi que les
modalités de transfert des biens
appartenant à l'état ou un établissement
publics affectés au logement des
étudiants aux collectivités
territoriales soit actuellement en phase
de concertation pouvez vous monsieur le
ministre nous apporter des précisions à
ce sujet je souhaite que le décret
déterminant les conditions dans
lesquelles les établissements publics à
caractère scientifique culturel et
professionnel contractant avec les
institutions étrangères ou
internationales université où nous puis
être lui aussi publié prochainement je
vais dire que la récente mission d'une
délégation de notre commission qui s'est
rendue le mois dernier au maroc nous a
montré que cette coopération pouvait
constituer un élément essentiel pour le
renforcement des échanges universitaires
et scientifiques
enfin toutes les dispositions de la loi
relative à l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel sont désormais applicable
même si le décret définissant les
conditions de contribution des éditeurs
de services de télévision à la
production audiovisuelle indépendante
dispositions introduites dans la loi à
l'initiative du sénat a pris près d'un
an de retard par rapport à la date
annoncée initialement
voilà monsieur le président monsieur
musique mes chers collègues
l'essentiel de ce que j'avais à partager
avec vous pour ce pour ce bilan annuel
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci madame la présidente je vais
donner la parole maintenant vice
président de la commission développement
durable notre collègue jean jacques
filleul
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le bilan de
la bloquer d'application des lois suivi
par la commission du développement
durable des infrastructures de
l'équipement de l'aménagement du
territoire fait lui aussi apparaître les
grandes tendances mises en avant par les
autres commission permanente du sénat
une amélioration relative dans la mise
en application des lois mais un taux
encore insuffisant de mesures prises
dans un délai raisonnable et par voie de
conséquence des marges de progrès qui
nous paraissent encore substantielles
plus précisément qu avons-nous relevé
cette année deux motifs de satisfaction
d'abord
premièrement sur un plan quantitatif
cinq lois dont nous assurons le suivi
sont devenus totalement applicable entre
le 1er octobre 2013 et le 31 mars 2015
on évoquerait deux en particulier la loi
du 16 avril 2013 relatives à
l'indépendance de l'expertisé en matière
de santé
et d'environnement et la protection des
lanceurs d'alerté dont l'origine revient
à une initiative du groupe écologiste du
sénat de décret du 26 décembre 2014 ont
permis de la rendent pleinement
applicable l'un en fixant la composition
et le fonctionnement de la commission
nationale de la déontologie et des
alertes en matière de santé publique et
d'environnement
l'autre en précisant la liste des
établissements et organismes devant
tenir un registre des alertes
c'est un vrai motif de satisfaction pour
une loi importante voulue par notre
assemblée
la loi du 1er juillet 2014 relative aux
activités privées de protection des
navires
conformément aux engagements pris par le
gouvernement est dans un contexte
d'urgence face à la résurgence de la
piraterie maritime l'ensemble des
mesures réglementaires a été publié
avant la fin de l'année 2014 soit dans
les six mois du vote de la loi ce dont
nous nous félicitons mais qui devrait
évidemment être la norme
deuxième motif de satisfaction aucune
des lois suivi par notre commission
n'est totalement inapplicable au 31 mars
toutes ont fait l'objet d'au moins une
mesure réglementaire d'application
ce qui n'a pas toujours été le cas dans
le passé voilà pour les points positifs
et comme les années précédentes
plusieurs motifs d'insatisfaction
demeure jean développerez 3 le premier
35% des lois adoptées au cours des dix
dernières années et qui relèvent du
champ de compétence
notre commission sont encore en attente
de mesures d'application
ce qui est bien entendu sur nous
beaucoup trop en effet sur les 34 kw à
voter au cours de cette période 12 ne
sont encore que partiellement applicable
et seuls cinq d'entre elles ont fait
l'objet d'une nouvelle mesure
d'application entre le 1er avril 2014 et
le 31 mars 2015
deuxième observation aucun rapport sur
la mise en application des lois votées
par notre commission nous a été
transmise par le goût du gouvernement
dans les six mois suivant leur entrée en
vigueur
le principe de cette transmission est
pourtant posé par l'article 67 de la
roy keane du 9 décembre 2004 de
simplification du droit
déjà cité troisième constat le retard
voire l'absence de remise des multiples
rapports d'informations demandé au
gouvernement au travers des dispositions
législatives que nous votons sur les 53
rapport d'information demandé au
gouvernement depuis le 1er octobre 2004
28 ont été remis soit à peine plus de la
moitié au cours de l'année parlementaire
2013 2014
seul un rapport intéressant notre
commission a été transmise au sénat le
rapport sur la mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie nationale de développement
durable 2010-2013
cela témoigne malheureusement de
l'inutilité des amendements
parlementaires demandant de tels
rapports certes nous avons parfois
tendance à encombrer l'administration
par des demandes si nutile ou
redondantes mais il arrive que de tels
rapports soient pleinement justifiée il
est bien dommage alors de constater que
le gouvernement n'accorde aucune
importance au respect des des mesures
votées avant de terminer mon propos je
voudrais insister sur une loi
emblématique votée l'an dernier la loi
du 4 août 2014 portant sur la réforme
ferroviaire
plusieurs textes d'application déjà été
prises notamment sur les nouvelles
instances mises en place et sur les
missions des différents établissements
créés mais reste à prendre un certain
nombre de textes particulièrement
sensible et important tel que le décrit
socle qui doit fixer les règles sociales
communes aux entreprises ferroviaires et
aux gestionnaires d'infrastructures le
décret relatif aux services internes de
sécurité de la sncf ou encore le décret
précisant les modalités d'application
des transferts de propriété du domaine
public ferroviaire au profit des régions
nous attendons également le décret
précisant les formalités à remplir par
les entreprises ferroviaires pour le
versement de la contribution locale
temporaire créé à l'initiative du sénat
pour financer les aménagements
extérieurs d'une gare ferroviaire de
voyageurs
ce sont des mesures importantes qui ne
saurait être encore retardées nous
estimons nécessaire qu'elle soit prise
dans les meilleurs délais il en va du
succès de la réforme d'un système
ferroviaire
qu'elle savait juste savez monsieur le
président nos ministres je suis très
attaché je remercie
merci monsieur le président j'ai donné
maintenant la parole à la présidente de
la commission des finances comme la
présidente michèle andré la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je
commencerai par dire ma satisfaction que
le sénat continue de s'investir
activement dans le contrôle de la mise
en oeuvre des lois et je veux remercier
ici particulièrement claude bérit-debat
pour son implication sur ce sujet la
commission des finances est
particulièrement concernée par le suivi
de la mise en application des lois
puisque 20 à 30 % de l'ensemble des
textes réglementaires attendues chaque
année à ce titre se rapportent à des
lois qu'elle a traités au fond l'année
dernière nous avons même connu un pic
avec 37%
je dirais d'abord un mot des principales
statistiques au cours de la période de
contrôler les deux tiers des textes
attendus sont parus ce qui est plus que
l'année dernière mais un peu moins que
la précédente
beaucoup moins de textes ont été pris
dans le délai de référence de six mois
44% contre les trois quarts l'année
dernière et les deux tiers il y a deux
ans et seulement 2 des 11 rapport
attendu nous ont été remis ce qui sans
doute nécessitera de s'interroger sur
les demandes de rapports que nous
formulons nous mêmes parlementaires en
général je voudrais maintenant évoquer
quelques caractéristiques de la manière
dont sont mises en oeuvre les lois que
nous votons sange rue sans originalité
on trouve encore des exemples de mesures
qui ne sont pas mises en oeuvre car
l'absence de textes d'application peut
être qualifié de blow quand c'est le cas
de la tgap sur les sacs plastiques
au contraire notre disposition sont
appliquées alors même que tous les
textes nécessaires ne sont pas parus il
en va ainsi de crédit d'impôt qui sont
accordés sans attendre que tous les
critères d'éligibilité soit opérationnel
c'est le cas de l'éco conditionnalité du
crédit d'impôt développement durable
décidé en 2012 appliquée seulement
depuis 2014 enfin en matière de
réglementation bancaire et financière
l'évolution rapide du droit européen
brun souvent nos lois comme leurs textes
d'application très vite obsolète
c'est à se demander si nous n'entrons
pas dans une ère de législation à durée
déterminée je voudrais évoquer de loi
dans la mise en oeuvre et suivi avec
attention par la commission des finances
nous sommes à trois semaines de l'entrée
en vigueur de la règle de séparation des
activités bancaires
issu de la loi du 26 juillet 2013 la
commission des finances a suivi de près
notamment par ces auditions publiques la
préparation de l'entrée en vigueur de
cette règle l'examen de l'effet combiné
des textes réglementaires successifs
nous a permis de constater que le
contrôle de l'effectivité de la règle
avait conduit à doter le régulateur de
nouveaux pouvoirs de contrôle très
important non seulement sur les
nouvelles filiales contenant les
activités dites risquées mais aussi sur
les maisons mères deuxième et la mise en
oeuvre plus ou moins rapide d'une
disposition législative qui ne repose
pas sur les textes réglementaires
je pense à la très importante question
de la révision des valeurs locatives des
locaux professionnels engagés depuis
relancé en 2012 soumise un calendrier
très difficile puisqu'il exige que les
services de l'état réalise dans des
délais très brefs
les difficiles simulation nécessaire
j'insiste sur ce point car les
ajustements du calendrier de mise en
oeuvre de cette loi résulte de
considérations techniques et non des
conséquences supposées de la réforme
puisque précisément les simulations
n'ont pas encore été réalisées ces
exemples me permette de conclure en
considérant que ce travail annuel est
nécessaire mais que c'est bien au
quotidien lorsque nous suivons la mise
en oeuvre des réformes que nous votons
et que nous utilisons nos prérogatives
en matière de contrôle que nous exerçons
l'essentiel de notre suivi de
l'application des lois
merci de votre attention merci madame la
présidente recueil heureux la
présentation des rapports
le président de la commission des lois
président philippe bas
merci monsieur le président au delà de
sa dimension statistiques l'adoption des
mesures d'application des lois dans un
délai raisonnable constitue l'un des
corollaires du respect de la volonté du
législateur c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'a suivi des mesures
réglementaires doit être fait tant du
point de vue quantitatif que qualitatif
je planque quantitatif le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que bien que des
progrès aient été constatés l'objectif
annoncé depuis 2012 d'un taux
d'application des lois de 100% six mois
après la fin de la période de référence
est loin d'être atteinte
pour les lois promulguées en 2013-2014
et suivait au fond par la commission des
lois un peu plus de la moitié des
mesures réglementaires prévues ont été
prises 54%
autrement dit alors que la situation
apparaissait satisfaisante l'an dernier
avec un taux d'application de 92 pour
cent principalement en raison du fait
que le nombre de mesures d'application
prévues au cours de la période de
référence avait chuté en valeur absolue
on regarde les périodes précédentes
notre taux d'application s'inscrit cette
année davantage dans la suite des taux
constatés auparavant et ce n'est pas
satisfaisant
certes comme chaque année rappelons
qu'un tel taux doit être nuancée d'une
part il ne traduit pas davantage que
lors des sessions précédentes l'aspect
qualitatif des mesures prises d'autre
part a contrario des mesures
d'application secondaires peuvent ne pas
avoir été prises et diminuer le taux de
mise en application d'une loi alors même
que celle ci est parfaitement appliquées
et que l'essentiel du dispositif est en
place sur le terrain
cependant personne ne peut se satisfaire
de constater année après année que près
d'une mesure réglementaire sur deux ne
soit pas adoptée six mois après la fin
de la session
je tiens en deuxième lieu à préciser que
ce travail de suivi des mesures
d'application est l'occasion une fois de
plus de constater que la charge de
travail à laquelle notre commission a
fait face s'est encore amplifiée si l'on
compte toutes les situations possibles
notre commission a examiné 44 texte au
fond au cours de la période auxquels
s'ajoutent 29 avis dont 21 budgétaire 13
rapports d'information et 5 rapports
relatifs à des propositions de
résolution c'est un niveau d'activité
plus important encore que celui constaté
lors de la session précédente et jamais
atteint auparavant
je n'insiste pas mes chers collègues sur
ces deux éléments statistiques que vous
aurez l'occasion d'examiner plus en
détail dans le rapport annuel sur
l'application des lois
plutôt que de détailler ces données vous
me permettrai monsieur le ministre
cette année d'attirer plus
particulièrement votre attention sur
trois lois de la période de référence
dont certaines mesures réglementaires
n'ont pas encore étape était adopté il
s'agit d'abord de la loi d'août 2014 sur
l'individualisation des peines quatre
des six mesures d'application n'ont
toujours pas été prise alors que le
gouvernement avait pourtant souhaité
engager la procédure accélérée sur ce
texte
et là il ya une incohérence de la part
du gouvernement
je ne sais pas s'il faut aller jusqu'à y
voir le signe d'une difficulté à
appliquer cette loi mais ils savent y
dix mois après sa promulgation d'une
donnée surprenante en particulier
peut-être disposez-vous d'éléments
d'information sur le décret en conseil
d'état prévu à l'article 35 de la loi
cette mesure qui n'est pas adoptée
encore doit pourtant permettre de rendre
effective la faculté de nez aux
officiers de police judiciaire
d'effectuer sur autorisation du produit
du procureur des transactions pénales
n'est tout de même pas anodin dans le
dispositif législatif dont il est
question
il en va de même dans des proportions
plus importantes encore de la loi de
janvier 2014 de modernisation de
l'action publique territoriale et
d'affirmation des mets des métropoles 37
mesures réglementaires prévues
n'était toujours pas prise au 31 mars
ce constat n'est pas de nature à
satisfaire notre commission un an et
demi après la promulgation de la loi
où en est le décret en conseil d'état
prévu à l'article 58 qui doit déterminer
la nature des biens pris en compte ainsi
que les critères d'éligibilité au fond
pour la réparation des dommages causés
aux biens des collectivités par lesquels
les calamités publiques
enfin la loi du 27 mai 2014 portant
transposition de la directive du
parlement européen et du conseil de mai
2012 relatives au droit à l'information
dans le cadre des procédures pénales
n'est toujours pas pleinement applicable
le décret prévu à l'article 11 est
toujours en attente
j'ai choisi ces données et ces trois
mesures réglementaires nole encore prise
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
parce qu'ils illustrent bien tout
l'intérêt pour notre assemblée d'être
attentive à la question de l'application
des lois
monsieur le président après ces
contributions de chacune des commissions
dans la suite du débat la parole et deux
orateurs des groupes qu'ils ont souhaité
monsieur patrick à battre pour le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen vous
avez la parole pour sept minutes
merci mme président seul ministre chers
collègues en abordant le bilan de
l'application des lois nous interrogeons
au fond la performance du processus
démocratique
les parlementaires que nous sommes sont
au coeur de ce processus et nous
trouvons aujourd'hui précisément à
croiser de nos deux fonctions nos
missions élaboration de la loi et le
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement le
principe démocratique ne peut être
garantie par la seule existence de
débats parlementaires aussi enrichissant
soit il mais doit se traduire par une
mise en application des lois qui sont
votées qu'elle portait à notre travail
si elle ne débouche pas sur une mise en
oeuvre réelle des mesures élaboré et
voté
nous nous livrons chaque année à ce
débat constatant le manière assez
régulière
manquement de façon quasiment permanente
le processus démocratique
malgré certains progrès progrès pardon
nous ne pouvons toujours pas atteindre
le taux effectif idéal qui devait être
être une loi est celui réellement mise
en oeuvre de 200% dans les dd un
principe simple doit être rappelé toute
loi votée doit être appliquée et seuls
ses tissus doit nous satisfaire loin des
60 à 65% actuelle cela est d'autant plus
important que le taux d'application des
lois d'initiative parlementaire est plus
faible que celui d'initiative
gouvernementale et que celui ci tend à
être encore moins élevés quand il s'agit
du sénat ainsi qu'un en application des
lois met à mal les droits du parlement
de notre assemblée et donc d'une
initiative législative des groupes
parlementaires qui ne disposent pour
thor pour valoriser leur initiative que
de peu d espace dédié aux propositions
de loi qui par ailleurs sont déjà rares
nous constatons également des
manquements ce qui concerne les rapports
du gouvernement au parlement
prescrit par la loi ils sont pourtant
utile puisqu'il permet au parlement
d'exercer un contrôle sur l'action du
gouvernement
au-delà de ces constats je pense que la
question de l'application des lois a
beaucoup à voir avec les conditions dans
lesquelles celles ci sont présentés et
adoptés
s'il est vrai pour en revenir au rapport
que le nombre de rapports demandés au
gouvernement est important et donc cher
quelquefois chers collègues président de
la commission des affaires économiques
voire redondant comme le disait notre
président de la commission du
développement durable est la conséquence
pour partie au moins est non négligeable
de la possibilité pour un groupe
parlementaire de proposer des mesures
des mesures législatives engageant les
finances de l'état nous ne pouvons donc
pas présenté et discuté des propositions
elles sont dans ce cas là invariablement
censuré par la commission des finances
et n'apparaissent à aucun moment dans le
débat public donc très souvent nous
sommes contraints pour faire avancer le
débat d'idées
on est on est là pour ça et envisageait
des alternatives
ce serait bien a demandé des rapports
ne vaudrait-il pas mieux laisser
s'exercer à plein le débat démocratique
et ne pas entraver le droit d'amendement
en laissant les parlementaires s'emparer
de tous les sujets qui tarde bien sûr ce
qu'il ne soit pas adopté le jeu
majoritaire et la responsabilité
s'exerce en par la suite nous pourrions
peut-être éviter l'inflation de rapports
et donc l'inflation de rapports non
rendu ceci étant nous continuons de
faire face à une avalanche de textes qui
peinent à trouver leur place dans un
calendrier chargé maintenant désormais à
des cessions qui non plus
d'extraordinaire que le nom et à un
recours trop important à la procédure
accélérée ou pire encore aux lois
d'habilitation qui autorise le
gouvernement à légiférer par voie
d'ordonnancé mise en relation avec
l'impossibilité de mettre en oeuvre
toutes les lois qui sont votées une
réflexion sur l'utilité et les bienfaits
de ces méthodes doit être engagée cette
surcharge nuit à la qualité du travail
parlementaire contredit l'exigence
essentielle de stabilité de sécurité et
de lisibilité de la loi pour les
citoyens ceci étant en conclusion et
vous l'aurez compris cher collègue
monsieur le président les nous
considérons que les progrès accomplis
actuellement son réel n'est qu'ils sont
encore largement insuffisant
merci merci vos chers collègues la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean claude requier pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique social
européen
merci monsieur le président hamid une
chers collègues le débat le sénat débat
aujourd'hui pour lancer une gamme voit
son histoire de l'application des lois
par assemblée a joué un rôle précurseur
dans le contrôle de l'application des
lois
chaque commission assure depuis 1971 le
suivi de l'application des textes
qu'elle a examinées entre novembre 2011
et 2014
la commission pour l'application des
lois honda organe a donc créé par le
sénat s'est acquitté de cette émission
sous l'égide de notre collègue david
assouline son président
ses exploits yann n'a pas été reconduite
lors du renouvellement d'octobre 2014
dans le souci de restituer aux
commissions permanentes la plénitude de
leurs prérogatives de contrôle
il ne s'agit pas là d'un débat il tire
une technique derrière se cachent des
enjeux importants pour le concitoyen qui
attendent les effets bien fait des lois
que nous avons voté ces derniers mois
consommation santé économie réelle
et comme m comment donc encore
dernièrement les avantages à voter une
loi permettant le nombre de jours de
repos à un parent d'enfants gravement
malades
les dispositions relatives à la fonction
publique mon père thomas été publié que
très récemment a dit le rapporteur tout
à l'heure mais il est vrai que le délai
moyenne de parution des textes
d'application et de plus de huit mois
comme le note le rapport de notre
collègue claude bérit débat
le taux d'application des lois grâce 14e
les dictatures tourner autour a
aujourd'hui aux alentours de 65 5%
même s'il existe parfois des écarts
notables entre textes votés wilaya
générale la tendance est à
l'amélioration du taux d'application des
lois se tourner l'application 6 points 1
essai semble insuffisant est cependant
largement meilleur que les pourcentages
est très médiocre d'avant 2010 entre
seulement 15 et 30 pourtant nous ne
pouvons regretter
nous pouvons que regretter l'engagement
de la procédure accélérée qui est
devenue une procédure quasi normal
cette fois cela n'a pas permis
d'améliorer encore ce taux d'application
une fois de plus on ne constate aucune
différence entre ce taux est celui qui
est enregistrée pour les lois pour
lesquels la procédure parlementaire
normale était suivi la procédure
accélérée et ainsi d de lui un prétexte
pour se passer deuxième lecture en scène
surchargé de nouveaux textes à l'ordre
du jour parlementaire au rythme déjà
effréné le jour le soir et même parfois
même jusqu'au bout de la nuit
les causes de retard ou de carence dans
l'application des lois sont multiples le
retard peut constituer peut résulter une
volonté politique de la part du
gouvernement à désaccord avec une loi
votée par le parlement ou même en
désaccord avec un de ses membres leurs
auteurs peuvent également être causées
par des bombes raisons techniques des
légumes des d'élaboration des dégrés
obligations grecques
xavi complexité des questions à régler
dit la garde de vue entre ministres et
moi elle rédaction de la loi qui
n'hésite son interprétation
il n'existe pas le véritable contrainte
de pouvait obliger pouvoir inventer à
s'acquitter de sa mission dans les
délais raisonnables
c'est ce constat qui a conduit le groupe
rdse a déposé une proposition de loi
adoptée par le sait la tende à
reconnaître une présomption d'intérêt à
agir des parlementaires en matière
d'excès de pouvoir
il s'agissait d'affermir la mission de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement par
le parlement
que prévoit depuis la réforme de 2008
l'article 24 de la constitution
les docteurs la proposition de loi avait
à ce propos rappelé que le contrôle du
parlement revêt une nature informelle
par le biais du contrôle de
l'application des lois et des mesures
réglementaires d'application
la carence du pouvoir enterrer dicter
les besoins alimentaires d'application
d'un délai raisonnable la dénaturation
de l'ocde les parlements ou encore
l'empiètement sur la compétence du
pouvoir législatif ne peuvent faire
l'objet de sanctions du parlement
nous avons encore vu avec la proposition
de loi visant à simplifier la saisine du
conseil national d'évaluation des normes
et plusieurs commissions permanentes ont
encore et d'année déploré que ces
règlements d'application ne soit pas
conforme à l'intention du législateur
il assure donc pas une mise en oeuvre si
dell des mesures législatives
quel sens s'est appliqué entre pau et
attirante attention le rapport aux
autres collègues bérit débat sur le
souligne que le taux de présentation des
rapports demandés par le parlement reste
à mener encore très médiocre et que sur
un moyen des dix ans des dites dernière
session parlons seulement ça de bon sens
des lois demande un rapport ont été
suivies d'effet nous souhaiterions aller
plus loin encore dans ce constat le
législateur multiplient les demandes de
rapports but allemand dans la discussion
que l'oat sont massés au projet de loi
relatif à crise énergétique
quasiment chaque article propose rapport
personnellement je suis très réticent à
tous ces rapports et il me vient à
l'esprit cette phrase du président
américain eisenhower ttrs ennemis
général militaire qui aimait dire à ses
collaborateurs faites moi un schéma car
un schéma à nice où en plus lent que le
plombier rapport ces rapports
constituent ainsi les véritables mesures
législatives normative
ils deviennent des palliatifs à l'action
du gouvernement est un disciple sur la
section pionners être mené à la mangue
même du projet de loi
quid de l'étude d'impact nous aurons
prochainement on a reparlé lors de
l'examen de ce pour quoi ils sont de loi
organique relative aux études d'impact
nous savons que quand nous votons ce
type de disposition le sort qui lui sera
réservé les lois ne rapport qu'on dise
donc à dessaisir le parlement de ses
prérogatives
ce qui n'est pas souhaitable il y aura
encore beaucoup pas dire ce sujet du
partage des compétences entre pouvoir
exécutif et législatif
nous conclurons un site et une
appréciation qui pourra pas être sur un
bulletin scolaire les efforts à la
matière sont à poursuivre il faut
persévérer particulièrement du côté de
l'exécutif dont la mission est
d'expliquer toujours mieux et toujours
plus vite merci on essaiera la prochaine
fois de le faire on schéma aussi c'est
une excellente suggestion
merci mon cher collègue voilà pour ce
bilan annuel de l'application des lois
je vous rappelle que le sénat est en
pointe depuis longtemps déjà sur le
suivi de l'application de la loi les
sénateurs socialistes claude bérit débat
qui était en charge du rapport cette
année a souligné de nombreux points
positifs avec des résultats stables par
rapport à la session précédente
notamment un taux de 65% de parution des
textes d'application et un délai
d'environ huit mois entre la loi et la
parution des décrets d'application il a
également souligné certains points noirs
notamment au niveau des rapports
demandés par le parlement et le tall a
en revanche restent insuffisants vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire à 15 heures je vous
retrouve pour les questions cribles
consacré aux dotations globales de
fonctionnement un sujet très important
ici au sénat très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires